bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono bravi j
ed oggi siamo su pente del crowne red ha
vestito di rosso per questo evento
incredibile anche babbo natale rosso per
questo gioco è un videogame che per chi
non lo conoscesse si ci si dà le botte
forti in faccia l'avevo giocato qualche
mese fa ma l'hanno giornata da quella
volta lì e non so bene come cosa chiesto
guardi ora come beve beve si gira come
se ci avessi la peste bubbonica in
faccia posso dire che assicura ecco che
cazzo credi che cazzo beh mi levo è
diverso dall'anno aggiornatissimo tipo
hanno aggiunto un sacco di roba
vorrebbero picchiarmi guardano tutti
come se fossi tipo malvivente terrorista
che belle facce sentiti 86 istituto qui
io mi prendo questa sera o quanto
mischia scusate non volevo rovinare la
festa tra voi gli stronzi
gli incazzati perché questi che si cosa
fanno
io ho tolto la sedia 1 e questi si
picchiano per quale motivo la cover lo
scriviamo le loro nomi ci guarda legge
casinò seriamente ragazzi io ho sotto
mori pudico il mondo nomi di più in cui
in facciamole buoi o cosa cazzo l'ho
letta nel tutti i controlli metri che so
l'ho letto ma cui si lanciano le cose
con f chemical che mira incredibile un
occhio di fiori che lì non si chiude
scarica veloce occupato grazie ho detto
che occupavo de c'è un tizio dietro che
ti sta picchiando il collo non so se te
ne sei accorto bravo si può passare da
che no no no no sulle teste sulle teste
test e prove allora va bene che il
bellissimo gravi e ragazza vissi mi
erano 6 brown incazzare sono un
complimento e prove di questo microfono
non ti serve tanto non sai catania non
ti serve e vabbè regalo senza niente
ecco alla madonna
[Musica]
sono morti tutti in fila scusate ragazzi
non volevo vi regalo anche questo vi
regalo anche di un bicchiere di ottimo
chardonnay perfetto è un'altra sedia
segue questa idea è che ha più buona di
marca ricevo ragazzi nell'altro episodio
di paint the town red non si menavano
tutti ce ne senso erano tutti contro di
me c'è tutti questi erano contro di me
quindi era un po abbastanza infattibile
come gioco quella chitarra nocenti file
secondo summer che cazzo vuoi cioè una
roba che non capivo ok ma inizio né mi
sono dimenticato che una minima menato
malmenato kills 5 su 70 perché ci sono
possa uccidere nel 78 lavora come si
menano anche mentre sono sdraiato in
botte da orbi dove ragazzi questa è la
riprova facciamone una seria prendo
posso prendere una mannaia the bear da
la mannaia notaio zio
ops quanto mi dispiace richiede o
tagliato un braccio alla madonna cosa fa
zio sono qui è anche in tizio e dovrei
tagliarti i problemi che qualche vecchia
birra gratis gli era gratis senza
software edius power rr usa ma ora
vediamo che sarà cos'è cos'è shockwave
che figo e data ragazzi io sono clark
kent non lo sapevate ma lo sono posso
prendere microfono per spaccarmi la
faccia grazie non lo devo togliere il
microfono per che smettono di far musica
questo non c'è il naso queste board è
morto c'è manco in harry potter ha fatto
una fine così cosa fanno questi giorno
senti incazzare non ho fatto niente ma
sono incazzati per un motivo non lo so
oddio po di una chitarra trovato la
chitarra è bravo viene non adesso vieni
adesso vieni ti spacco il muso manco
fosse bravo bravo eccolo lì jimi hendrix
madonna celo celo shockwave
com addio come come come hai fatto a
sopravvivere al potere di jesus e
shockwave e quello berserk che cos'è
esplode tutto è bellissimo posso
scrivere sopra come se la prendono nel
culetto ragazzi cosa ho trovato venite
tutti qua che vi devo uccidere la
famiglia uno perfetto due o è morto 2 3
4 5 e sono morto io adesso mi sembrate
retro vade retro mani a cortona le
strettissime ragazzi non subito che come
non ha la mia bottiglia zio continuo a
far così vicano muore sono quello che si
suol dire un deficiente replay ragazza
fino a che non arrivò al secondo non
voglio cazzi mi chiama a saperlo prima
c'era scritto è nota ma non so leggere
non lo so non lo sapevo ragazzi non
avevo idea è la madonna una chitarra te
in testa al primo che passa senza motivo
cavaco madonna che mira affetto pensa
credi non lo usano lo usano l'uso puoi
arrivare all'ultimo se continuo così non
mi serve neanche l'ultimo che ho fatti
fuori tutti prima a la mannaia mi son
dimenticato la mannaia la putain lo
smile shot 18 seguitemi seguitemi
seguitemi seguitemi bravi bravi vai giù
tutti giù tutti giù perfetto tutti i
ragazzi tutti giusto stranzi venite a me
venite che cosa vuoi tu cosa vuoi
niente siamo ragazzi smythe smythe ci
siamo eccolo come il sufficiente ma come
fermi per i temi non ce l'ho ancora che
è successo perché adesso ce l'ho e così
[Musica]
qualcosa mi che sbatte realizza le
persone
vai vai spara spara spara spara tutti è
fortissima
madonna il portello
e vabbè fighissimo smat e capita e
casinò gli sparo un berserk in faccia ci
siamo perché non è possibile cosa vieni
vieni noi o che lanciati la faccia
cervello e questo e verso materializzo
le persone pro venirmi addosso vieni
vieni sorridi e bellissimo cazzo che
figo il verso questo era un pugno
normale matos fasciato uguale chi cazzo
è questo
senti cracco e non è che facciamo
masterchef qua elevati dai [ __ ] ibra
se io picchio quest'uomo moro è una roba
che metal gear ha proprio la bandana
disney c'è un foro questo come sadomaso
c'è un frustino e in e miss mail on line
remaining ei tre mining server reining 7
nemici e il massimo dei nemici che si
possono avere nella vita fermino a più 6
sacco il re di 54 miche fortissima
parola gas e una mazza da baseball come
fai se così fosse eccoli bella regalo
vieni attimi nati uno zio prendi questo
ciao
giuro che se riescano a massa degli
ultimi due rido a1 reining
com ho vinto e questo far uscire dal bar
perfetto 78 su 78 ragazzi incredibile ci
ho messo anni marcelo fatta vacche
bordello bellissimo il geniale ragazza
bellissima è stata una figata va che
casino fatto di sotto don't let incaz
valigetta buona ragazzi è stato
veramente figo perché l'hanno cambiato
in meglio ci adesso veramente figo anche
prima ma adesso è veramente figo ci sono
un sacco di 9 tra l'altro ci sono un
miliardo ragazzi gli farò più avanti e
sportivi sapere se vi è piaciuto
questo momento io mi piace anche a
pazienti facebook e con il video
descrizione il city scrive di non ci
vediamo al prossimo video ei ragazzi